you know how are you with criticism
because here's how we're different i
don't
seek out uh-huh uh comments about myself
on the internet but i know that you read
stuff you spend time you read dms and
stuff i would that's just something i
would never do well i read them because
i read uh like nasty come ons on why
won't you date me so i like go through
my dms and whatnot but um yeah if
somebody wants to say something mean to
me that's fine comedy subjective my
check's clear if that makes you feel
better then like by all means uh sure
i'll i'll retweet you i'll respond to
you my favorite one was this man was
like i hate you you suck you stop doing
comedy kill yourself and i was like did
that make you feel better and then they
wrote back i was having a really bad day
i'm sorry i directed it at you keep
making people laugh but not me
wait was this the 70 year old
same guy
probably his son or something uh
but i was like i love that you double
that it was very funny
but also um
i think this is true most of the time if
someone's writing something horrible
if you could immediately knock on their
door
you would probably encounter someone who
didn't really feel that way about you
yeah there's a lot of stuff online it's
first of all
i think a lot of people who think online
is to hate that's it's it's for extremes
you're the best in the world or i wish
you would die you're satan and there's
no in between but if you did confront
those people in real life i don't think
a lot of them would would
double down on that feeling yeah i think
very few people be like no i meant it
[ __ ] you yeah but i think most people
are like oh i was just looking for
attention and
if you need attention like that's fine
i don't mind when people have negative
things to say right because everything
is subjective do you know what i mean i
wish i could say i do
um
i
like what difference does it make to
your life well that's the problem is
that i think deep down
that's something about myself that i
wish i could change i wish i had a
little bit more
um
what the [ __ ] in me i think that would
that would be very good for me to have
that because
i'm still if i feel that someone's
displeased my initial reaction now it
doesn't mean i can't recover from it is
what did i do wrong did i offend them in
some way is there a way i could fix this
and i wish i didn't have that i wish uh
um i had or i wish i had less than that
if my dial is up to 11. i wish i could
take it down to like four i think well
if someone says something negative about
you and you know you didn't actually
offend them just like open your bank
account after and be like that's good
that's a good idea
my wife won't let me have access
she controls the money and she's the one
saying
i bought
millions and millions of dollars worth
of ventriloquist dummies and my wife got
legal control
of
and in the intervention all the
ventriloquist dummies were there and
they sided with my wife i liked it chase
got up
and you were doing their
voices a voice running to each one yeah
it's really sad
there's no money for your children to
have an education
and uh you need to get help well there's
a program for you so uh i like this this
reality where she didn't just leave you
you know she's like no
no no she wants a few more she wants a
few more years
she sees that i'm still an earner she
wants a few more years and then she'll
put me in the home
where everyone there will say
i yeah big fan but we don't like it
it doesn't work for me